all right uh welcome to the ddps seminar
everyone before we introduce our invited
speaker let's go over some rules and
Logistics the same rules and Logistics I
have been um I I have been saying for
every ddps seminar okay first of all
please mute yourself during the talk uh
but if you have questions you can unmute
and ask questions or use a chat room to
post your question so that we can
address them in Q session second today's
ddps seminar is open to external
audiences um therefore no classifi
discussion is allowed and finally The
Talk today will be recorded and uploaded
in our YouTube channel that's about it
now let me briefly introduce our speaker
today it is an um honor um it's a great
honor to host Dr Doug James who is a
professor of computer science at
Stanford University and a member of
Stanford's Center for computer research
in music and Acoustics and the institute
for computational and mathematical
engineering uh
icme uh he has been a Consulting senior
research scientist at Nvidia research
since
2022 he holds three degrees in Applied
Mathematics including a PhD in uh 2001
from the University of British Colombia
in 2002 he joined the school of computer
science at carneg melon University as an
assistant professor and later became an
associate professor of the computer
science at Corell University his
research interests include computer
Graphics computer sound physically based
modeling and animation and reduced order
physics models dog is a re Ian of the
National Science Foundation Courier
award and the fellow of both the Alfred
slon foundation and the gugenheim
foundation he received the ACM seagar uh
2021 uh computer Graphics Achievement
Award a 2012 technical Achievement Award
from the Academia of Motion Picture Arts
and Sciences for the wavelet ulence and
2013 katayanagi emerging leadership
prize from the K melon University and
Tokyo University of Technology he was
the technical paper program chair of ACM
cigar
2015 and a Consulting senior research
scientist at Pixar Animation uh Studios
from 2015 to 2020 all right today doc uh
we'll talk about recent progress in
reduced order modeling for computer
graphics and sounds I'm sure he's going
to give a v talk no doubt about it so
please be prepared now let me ask a
question to dog just to make this St
somewhat informal is is it okay to ask
some question dog yeah please by all
means um you know ask questions at any
point I'm gonna I'm gonna uh you know go
through a lot of material and uh think
of the talk as kind of an advertisement
for for the material like find the
details in the paper I just don't have
time to go through everything but uh but
by all means if you have questions just
you know shoot this is fine okay the
first question is even before you give a
talk okay the um you
know I see that you are passionate not
only the computational science comp
computer science but also the music and
if you can share a your favorite music
piece with us uh
wow um yes I mean I love uh I guess I I
love all the things related to site and
such touch and sound and how that
relates to math and physics and uh it's
sort of always been one thing together
you know I don't know how about uh Paul
Gilbert's uh curse of Castle Dragon put
that on if you want to get your energy
levels up you know that will that will
get you going in the morning awesome
okay I don't know know of that music but
I will definitely try yeah amazing
guitarist okay thank you stage is yours
okay great um so thanks for coming to
the talk everybody um so I I've always
been excited uh you know for the last
you know 20 years about reduced order
modeling about how to make things fast
by doing things in low Dimensions
speeding up dynamics of deformable
models allowing that to be used to do
faster GPU rendering of the models the
motion and uh and being able to reduced
St representations for faster Collision
processing contact processing supporting
haptic feedback at kilohertz rates and
even sound without having to deform
everything so you know res models just I
I just love them but some things you
have to uh you know you need full
Dimensions to to do if you want a lot of
details and or things that you haven't
seen before or don't know what the basis
is and so that kind of leads to the
first part of the talk and the second
part is going to be about about fluids
and the sounds that water makes and how
to compute those using reduced order
models um so let me see how to do this
okay so um so the I guess I want to
start by thanking uh you know my PhD
students so this is worked by two
amazing PhD students uh the first one is
ays uh AIS has done a lot of incredible
work on um simulating deformable models
and that's related to the progressive
physics or
Progressive uh uh methods that she
developed that's the first part of the
talk second part is by congre and congr
has been working on um doing fast
simulation of fluid sounds and also uh
GPU Acoustics and things like that to
basically make the simulation of uh
everything we can visually animate also
has sound in a practical way so this
like the future is includes sound that's
a first class uh physical primitive um
okay so to start with this is the the
the the work on Progressive simulation
so the basic idea is that we want to be
able to compute things uh you know
resolution in a resolution Progressive
Way and uh and this work was with a
number of amazing collaborators so in
particular Danny Kaufman at Adobe it
also started out with Alec Jacobson and
Raymond and and others and so um this is
something that she's been working on for
a few years now and it's it's really
coming along the motivation is basically
you have you know maybe you want to do
design so you have a scene like this
uh you want to have like cloth and you
want to lay things out um with with uh
to do set design or to make a scene in
in a 3D modeling tool so there's all
kinds of materials there's contact uh
maybe you want to have cloth and shells
in these sort of environments and being
able to to manipulate physical models is
really tedious it's it's often very very
slow so you have this basic problem of
speed versus Fidelity which you know
this is a reduced order modeling session
so this is the basic story right uh like
we want you want it to be good but you
also want it to be fast and there's a
trade-off you have to make and a lot of
fun math to keep us employed um but you
know currently we can do stuff like this
you know you can pull on a piece of
cloth and then it can respond in real
time uh maybe it's on like a GPU or a
CPU whatever there's some amount of
parallelism that can be employed and but
you can't really make a you know it's
it's it's cool it does this in real time
but it's also Limited the other kind of
things we have to deal with are the
simulators have all kinds of limitations
so on the left we have like a you know
animation production quality system
Houdini uh which allows us to simulate
this cloth but it's got jittering
artifacts it's got intersections maybe
it has other problems depending on your
parameters that you didn't tune expertly
on the right is a like the
state-of-the-art and cloth design tool
clo Marvelous Designer has all these
fantastic materials but you know it's
not stable and maybe it'll blow up in
some cases so you try again right so how
do you get all of these things you know
how do you get uh reliable simulations
that are are also fast here's like a a
state-of-the-art simulator based on
incremental potential contact which is
kind of like a you know full-blown
elasticity solver with barrier methods
that are robust and allow you to make
sure it'll always work and not die but
it may take a long long time to get
these results um so minutes per frame or
you know hours per simulation but you'll
get something good but how do you design
or or or work with that if you're trying
to do design or animation so the other
thing that's really important is control
and um so it's not just that you it's
not just speed INF Fidelity the point is
you want to use this for for you know
art directable physics you want to
design something you want to make a
movie you want to do something with a
human in the loop but if you can't if
it's so slow you can't do it or if it's
no good it doesn't matter so here's a
shot from Incredibles 2 that I know some
people a Pixar spent a lot of time
thinking about like you have a scene
where a character's moving around they
have clothing and they're interacting
with cloth you know the sheets and so on
they're coming on the bed off the bed
and then at some frame in the middle of
this animation there's this shot right
and nothing in this scene is by accident
you know the way the cloth is exactly at
her knee line not too high not too low
and is is you know moving when she comes
on and off was by was on purpose right
so how do you make sure things do what
you want if you're working with a
physical simulator usually you you start
integrating with initial value problem
things go and then you get what you get
right but you want to control things so
you need to have uh A system that allows
you to work with it interactively
essentially um and people that made the
shot the TDS you know they have to do
all kinds of work to design forces and
ghost forces to push things just right
and and then they change the resolution
and hope it works better for the final
shot and this is really hard uh to do so
if we want interactiv interactivity and
high quality these are you know there's
at odds so um there's no free lunch but
what we want to do is be able to build a
tool initially I'm going to talk about
quasi static simulation so things like
draping a piece of cloth maybe you want
to explore different materials things
that are thin have nice buckling and
creases like this or maybe you want to
you know change the materials as you go
and move things around um so this is
just initially we're going to talk about
quasi Statics of cloth things that have
a flat rest shape and um so how do we
think of progressiveness in graphics so
there's all kinds of paradigms for
Progressive simulation um so on the left
is like 3D rendering right Monte Carlo
path tracing you can you can render
things a course level and then refine it
and get more detail as you go right and
on the right we have Progressive me M
Progressive geometry where you can have
a mesh you can simplify it you can build
a hierarchy of meshes and and you can
refine along the way but this isn't this
isn't like you know this isn't solid
mechanics but this is these are are are
ways people work with Progressive
representations it's super useful level
of detail make things fast you can see
results right away you can try things
out and then change things if you don't
get you would like for level of detail
the current state-ofthe-art of things
like nanite system and Unreal Engine
five which uses all all kinds of really
fine meshes at different levels of
detail and you can change these on the
Fly artists you know experts in fluid
simulation you know they use little
strokes of paint uh to get the the
background and then they add more detail
in a progressive way if you work in
solids you know then you know you may
sculpt things in a progressive way to to
get details where you want them so how
do we do this for claw simulation uh and
I want to emphasize that this is
different from um just the idea where
you simulate things at a course level
and then you and then you get something
and then you simulate in a fine level
and in the limit you know given some
Epsilon I'll tell you a Delta and you'll
get an accurate result we're not trying
to do uh refinement in a progressive way
to uh a a limit solution like you do in
numerical on house we're actually trying
to progressively refine a thing that
we're working on which maybe isn't as
different from from the limit case and
this is a really important distinction
um so for example here's a typical
problem with with direct simulation so
you you say okay I have to make this
shot I'm going to throw this blanket on
this guy and you simulate a cloth being
put down at a low resolution and you get
this result you say oh I like this it
goes under his chin and I don't know if
you can see my mouse can you see my
mouse see yep yes yes we can yeah okay
great so it goes under his chin and he's
got these nice wrinkles that's this is
what I want and so then you you change
the resolution and rerun the simulation
and wait a long time and you get this
and this is typical because uh now
you've got something that just doesn't
do the same thing it's uh you know it's
got fundamentally different wrinkles it
it it caught on the on the guy's nose
now so the shot is ruined uh so you if
you run something at a low res and get
something you like just increasing the
resolution doesn't give you something
consistent necessarily right in some
cases it may but in a lot of cases it
doesn't so everybody who does fluid
Dynam knows if you run you know smoke at
a low res and you get something that
goes looks nice in this way if you run
at a high res it may do something
totally different it may have you know
all kinds of more vortices and so on and
that's what you you want you know if
you're if you're designing something or
trying to do predictive simulation with
fluids or solids but for art directable
physics you want to direct something
quickly at low res and then refine it in
a way which adds plausible detail but
doesn't necessarily do something more
accurate and different you want it to be
consistent so this is the fundamental
challenge that we have to deal with um
okay so moving along another challenge
is cascadic methods are a natural
approach to this so what they do is they
basically say I have a CO Sim uh it's
doing something I like now what I'm
going to do um so I'm say draping this
piece of cloth on the left I'm going to
now prolong it to a finer mesh and then
and then use that as an initial guess
for the next
next phase of relaxation say of this uh
fine level simulation and this is kind
of like warm starting the the quasy
static solver and this you know this is
a reasonable thing to do but the problem
is the coar model is garbage really and
um so whatever Kinks and creases and
locking artifacts this you know coarse
cloth or shell model has are going to be
inherited by the warm start to the next
thing so now you've got this fine level
cloth model which if it was simulated
it's uh directly would give you
something nice like this but now because
you warm started it you baked in these
creases and locking the thing is not in
a very natural state and this is typical
of these kind of methods um they're
useful for interactive design because
they you know allow you to work course
and go fine but they have all these
problems and so what we really want is a
better course model a smarter course
model that is also consistent with the
finer scale and then people often you
know
multi- grid and multi-level methods are
are related to this but they're for you
know linear solvers or say nonlinear
solvers but they're not fundamentally
for uh Progressive uh art directable
physics they're just solvers right but
we can use them too but they don't they
don't solve this
problem okay so the next thing I want to
talk about is just like how do we get uh
interact interactive high quality cloth
well the basic approach to this is
progressiveness we're going to get both
of these by using a progressive approach
and this will also give us control so
we're going to start with a CO Sim and
build up in this case a quasi static
simulation so we'll pose the cloth in
some way in a coarse scale and then what
we can do is progressively refine the
simulation to get something better it's
not the same thing otherwise why would
we just do that um it's going to get
more detail and more you know finer
wrinkles and things like that but it's
still going to be consistent with what
we have so the rough shape of it will be
consist it's not going to fundamentally
do something else or pop out or fall
down or whatever and so this will give
us a consistent representation across
scales and it's also the simulator is
reliable so we're going to use a rock
solid simulator won't allow any
intersections or or artifacts and um
it's going to come at a cost but we're
going to pay the cost of the fine scale
and work quickly at the course scale at
any point in time you can interrupt the
simulation as it goes from course toine
and change parameters or work with it
and then just it'll just go back and you
can keep doing this over and over again
and then of course the key thing is that
we'll have interactive previews at every
stage of the process so working course
we'll always be able to see what's
happening and then we can refine it so
that's the basic idea of this original
PCS uh
method and um so here's the idea of
consistency so uh a level zero we have
something like this but as you refine it
the the simulator gets more detail you
can see that the the quality of the
folds are are finer and more resolved
but the thing is not fundamentally
buckling or creasing in a different way
it's doing something that's similar
maybe you could argue this is not the
most exciting example you know it's just
like a handkerchief on a ball right
nobody's GNA you know go to the movies
to see just this but it's it's it's
something that you know is clearly
consistent in space uh with What's
Happening Here like you could measure
the curvature and and Define some
measure of of consistency which we did
um the other thing you can do is you can
you can change the materials as you go
right so a cool thing about this is that
you can you know work with one material
and and then decide you want to change
it and get results for that too so you
can be working at a course scale and
then try out different things and
rapidly explore the space of of possible
uh materials and and outcomes which is
what you want to do for design the other
thing is that um we don't we can avoid
the artifacts of coar direct Sims
because okay so on the left here we just
have a cloth model uh that's simulated
at on this mesh and what you see is what
you get it's simulated in some you know
it's basically solving a Statics problem
with a Newton solver and you get
something like this but it has a lot of
artifacts that are representative of the
kind of failures of just really coarse
cloth
uh mesh models and uh whereas this one
here is smarter and the reason it's
smarter is basically because the coar
model that we're using here is doing
multiscale model reduction it's
basically using it's basically using
elastic forces and energies defined at
the finest level mesh and then
restricting these down to this so it's
using a much better shape model for its
elastic energies and so this thing
behaves like it's actually a finer scale
model so a a more of a cost to do this
but it's better than just using the
course model itself and the other thing
is that this model because it it knows
about the fine scale energies will when
you refine the mesh still behave in a
similar way so that's going to allow us
to have consistency across scales
because the course model is actually you
know knows about the fine scale model in
some specific ways and when you refine
the meshes um then you get something
here on the right which is consistent
with what we had on the left okay it
looks similar uh whereas the one on the
on the left is is got some different
artifacts things move around and it's
not as
consistent
um but the also the other thing is that
when we refine this and solve it at the
fine scale it is actually a converg
Newton solution corresponds to a you
know approximate Minima of the
energies okay um let me
see okay so this gives us speed up over
a direct simulation so here we can we
can drape the D the PCS simulation out
of coar scale and then when it gets to
its a relaxed position then refine it
and this is better than just uh directly
working with uh um the fine model itself
because you know this is just going to
take a longer time because it's just
times it's basically just time stepping
lots of these degrees of freedom in the
Newton solver um so working course is
much faster and in some cases it can be
arbitrarily fast because you can't
actually get the work done if you're
working at a course at a fine scale um
so this is a a sped up a session of of
somebody working with the system to
build an example I showed you in the
very beginning so there's a bust of a of
a of a character and then this piece of
cloth is being draped over over it and
then interactively manipulating it to
produce what you want so like the
typical design proc processes you don't
know what the final outcome is you're
trying to work with the system and the
media to figure out what's possible so
they're changing material parameters and
um and then they're also changing the
configuration and moving things around
so in this case you can translate rotate
and scale the uh collider and then and
the system of you know pushes it out in
this case because you've specified some
in feasible State and then grab it you
basically grab the clo and move it
around like you would in a typical
system and in this case the the person
is trying to move the cloth around uh
the the
character um and so this is the system
and so then as you get closer to your
goal then you can you can go ahead and
refine the actual resolution and it gets
of course much slower but by this point
the person's done so the artist has
basically found something they like
they've increase the resolution and then
they just wait for the the higher
quality result to to come into play but
all of the design work is done in a more
rapid prototyping course
scale okay so here's the the final
result so this is what they what they
designed um and you know it's only
1.5 a, I know, 1500 triangles and this
can be solved very quickly with a you
know direct solver basically and then um
this gets refined and and the end result
takes much longer but you know you get
something that's consistent you have to
wait but you don't have to you don't
have any anxiety you just have a coffee
and relax it's going to work
out um and here's a final render of that
of that of that draping
design so if you tried to work directly
on the the fine Sim it would be too slow
if you didn't work on the fine Sim you
just work work on course schim it
wouldn't be consistent so this solves
both those
problems um so the basic idea of the
method um I should keep an eye on the
time because I'm going to run out of I'm
you know run out of time here um so the
basic idea of the method is um you
basically want to take the cloth in some
initial State and then get to some final
converge
State
um you have a course preview and then
you can progressively refine this across
levels in a way that preserves the
Integrity of the simulation doesn't
introduce intersections or
artifacts um so this is done in an
incremental potential formulation so
we're basically minimizing some energy
of the system where you have membrane
and bending energies of the elastic
simulation and then you have this
contact a barrier for contact friction
and then a strain limiting potential
which is this is sort of incremental
potential contact formulation and this
will guarantee things don't
interpenetrate and it's solved using a
uh Newton with line search and some
robust solver and it may take a long
time but it'll it'll get there and
um and in order to to deal with the the
resolutions we have a prolongation
approach where you basically have this
mesh and it's basically subdivided or
prolonged to a finer a finer mesh and
then at each level basically you
essentially want to solve this problem
where there's a level L you have some
energy for that level and then you could
just solve each one of these separately
and it would kind of look like this um
and uh you know each one would have a
different different Minima and we want
to relate them by this initial guess xar
which is basically our our warm start um
but we don't want to do this exactly so
the problem is if you just solve each
level's energy separately then you're
going to have uh some problems the other
thing um I should mention is that in
order to make the process coherent in
time for somebody working with the
system we have a sort of pseudo Time by
adding an extra basically penalty term
which corresponds to like this kinetic
energy uh thing so you have a ma a mass
Norm on the change in position which
basically produces the kinetic energy
type energy in the system um so the
problem I talked about before where you
take a course model and then you refine
it and use a warm start with this will
give you artifacts for membrane locking
because the coar model is is a bad model
and it's going to put in artifacts that
when you refine as a warm start will be
hard to undo so if you like crease or
knot up your simulation the cloth is
going to have a hard time undoing that
and it may just say fine I'll just stay
here and but it's not a natural state
for the cloth to have these uh mesh
artifacts in it from a core scale so
instead of using each level separately
what we're going to do is we're going to
use the fine scale energies at at the
coarser scales and so in order to do
that we have a prolongation operator
which basically refines a a Sol a
solution or vector from one level to the
finest level and then what we do is we
evaluate the contact energies for the
barrier friction and string limiting at
the specific scale for the mesh you have
but the but the you know the membrane
and and the the bending energies are
going to be for the finest level okay
and this will make make it behave much
better it turns out you could do these
at a finer scale but it doesn't it's not
it's not worth it it'll turn out um so
this will basically will have uh good
contact handling constraints at the
current level for this specific geometry
and then we'll refine uh basically
evaluate the energies here and those
will get restricted back in a usual
multiscale model reduction kind of way
um and
so in this case then uh right um so this
gets all put in a Newton solver and um
in order to solve this of course you
have to compute derivatives and HS and
things like this and so this can get
expensive so the gradient of the energy
is just the forces on the system at the
scale and then the Hest involves two
parts the first part is going to be uh
you know the mass Matrix which which is
just there for for keeping it from you
know just for for coherence but then we
have the the potential the gradient of
the the energies of the fine scale uh
for the elastic energies and then the
contact Hess so this one is easy because
it's at the current level but this one
involves fine scale information so
there's the usual kind of you know how
do you evaluate the stiffness Matrix for
this reduced system using the fine scale
model um in this case because we're
we're just doing a Newton problem we
could do an inexact Newton solve and
just use the this Hess at the current
level and so this is this is a
simplification which we'll will'll speed
things up quite a bit um and so then the
uh you know Newton set proceeds and if
it's done right you get to a reasonable
feasible Minima and this is this is what
the system does and then in order to get
to the next step um uh you just keep
doing this incrementally and then you
convert to the the the solution the one
thing you have to watch out for is when
you change from one resolution to the
next you can mess things up by changing
the contact state so we have to make
sure that there's an intersection free
upsampling that happens and so we do
this by doing basically a polyhedral
subdivision we just refine the
parameterization not the geometry and
then and then we do a continuous
Collision detection to to basically
allow this thing to relax and take its
natural State and this uh can introduce
intersections but this is uh if it's
done properly uh in this way then we
we're able to you know make sure that
that we don't mess things up and it has
to also work for strain limiting because
if you allow things to get pushed around
as they change from run resolution to
neck you could introduce a lot of energy
by stretching something that doesn't
want to stretch and so that that energy
has got to be satisfied too so there's a
a whole tedious uh sequence of steps
that allow us to do this but we can
change resolutions as we go and then if
you want to go back and fix things you
can and and so this is uh this is the
interactive
workflow um okay how am I doing for time
so there's some consistency with the
with the the curvature if we look at
mean curvature between levels for our
model uh versus previous cascadic
approaches we basically win in every
every scenario that we looked at in the
paper um it's just a more consistent and
we can also have nested Collision
geometry not just a cloth but we can
have you know Progressive
representations of scenes that you know
allow us to um refine the geometry of
the scene as we go so this helps with
speeding up Collision detection
basically
um so here's a gallery of some different
simulations that were made changing the
bending stiffness the materials and then
here's an interactive workflow so after
9 Minutes of of working with the
simulator which is not much time given
that this to to do the solve it's like
it's about that time to actually do one
solve right or um so U you can't work at
the fine scale if we work in a
progressive way we can get get the work
done and here's a a larger scene I'm
just going to sort of speed this up but
somebody's you know working with the
system at course scales and there's
multiple layered pieces of cloth that
are sticking together and the thing
responds in a coarse way and then when
you stop moving things it starts
refining and adding more detail until
you change it again so this it's a fully
responsive system uh this is a prototype
it's not a product but you know you get
the idea and then you have multiple
pieces of interacting cloth and in the
final thing you have as many triangles
as you
want okay um so this is just for cloth
uh the next part is for shells and I
want to go through this more quickly
because it's more complicated but
basically these have nons smooth rest
States so they they have geometry that
when you refine them they're not just a
flat piece of cloth that's bent it's got
some inherent uh nonzero rest angles for
the for the shells shells are
interesting they have all kinds of
interesting behavior um but they're you
know more more expensive to simulate so
the usual problem of speed versus
Fidelity is even more interesting for
shells so if you if you try to use a
really course simulation uh you'll miss
all these fine details and buckling
effects um that that you need a a resolv
shell simulation for and you'll get all
kinds of locking locking effects I'm
just going to speed this up so here's
like a a direct simulation at a course
scale you get all kinds of artifacts
it's just terrible um so how do you get
this with the shell simulation um the
same sort of thing we did before uh only
works for subdivision connectivity uh
which also it subdivided a flat shape to
a flat shape but now with a with the
shell you know now we can do subdivision
surfaces but there's no details how do
we take a a specific detailed mesh and
work with it in this way we can't assume
it's a subdivision model um so we want
to take arbitrary fine geometry and then
build a hierarchy from that and use that
in a progressive simulation framework
but this is difficult because it's not
just a uh repeated subdivision
everything's not in plain um okay so
this is where this method Progressive
shell quasy Statics comes from still
quasy Statics but we take a
highresolution model and decimate it
using like a a quadric
simplification class of of method not
that one exactly and then from that we
have a hierarchy to refine it and so
here's a simulation that somebody's
working with the course model on and
they can you know pose this character
however they want and then refine it and
get the simulation course responding to
this is like a a shell balloon character
it has some some
details okay so at level zero you get
consistent Solutions as as these things
evolve and you get extra detail and
geometry that gets added in it's not
just a smooth limit surface and it's
just fundamentally better so the the
progressive simulation course model is
smart because it knows about fine scale
energies so when you refine it it's it's
consistent as well and it avoids locking
our effects and we can upsample the
context so here as we add more detail we
don't get inter penetrations and even in
this pretty challenging case uh things
just resolve and work and so you can do
something at a course simulation scale
and then keep increasing resolution the
contacts get resolved and there's no
inter penetrations and everything you
know just works um the details of it are
are fascinating but also they're going
to caus me to run out of time uh let me
see so we're going to do quasi Statics
again what we really want to do is
Dynamics that's the next paper uh before
the bubbles so let me let me just speed
this up a bit so previously we did quasi
Statics but now uh this only works for
subdivision connectivity um so the thing
we have here are we have the coar level
proxy energies using fine scale elastic
uh energy and then we have a safe
initialization but this only worked for
in plane stuff um so we could assume
that we just refined the triangle in
plain um so now uh we can use uh the
simplification to get uh a course model
but to refine it this is a problematic
thing and we also have to make sure that
when we when we prolongate it we don't
introduce inter penetrations which is
now harder and so those those are the
two things that this paper does there's
some prior work I want to skip that
doesn't solve it messes things up and
adds ghost forces I skip this and this
one it makes things dense so we want a
fast and um sparse prolongation so this
is based on edge collapse and there's
basically there's the basic thing is
that when you want to add an extra
degree of Freedom back you can do it in
the plane of the triangle using a
bicentric intrinsic coordinate but you
still need to go out of the plane to pop
the inflate the shell and this is the
extrinsic prolongation part
um and so as we do this we basically we
basically track a local frame of this
triangle and figure out where the ber
Center coordinate of the of the
coordinate is and then we add an
additional displacement off this in the
local frame and this is how the
prolongation works and there's a we show
that this actually works and it's it's
stable and gives us good energies which
is the key thing for simulation um and
so we're able to then prolongate this
and add detail and uh and the system uh
will work in order to initialize it um
we need to make sure that there's no
inter penetration introduced and so in
order to do that as you add more degrees
of freedom you have to check for
collisions and when you're doing these
Edge expansions so that you maintain a a
feasible simulation with no inter
penetrations and there's some details
about how this has to be done in a
robust way because you could have things
which are like you know a coar shell
model which is like a you know some
origami you know satellite thing all
packed in and then you want to add
degrees of freedom and there's no room
uh you have to make sure that this is
done robustly and so there's a a part of
the paper which is dedicated to this
part to to make sure that you can
inflate things in a way which uh is done
safely and uh I won't get into this
there's a randomized search method that
guarantees that it works uh and so if
you if you use this then you're you're
able to deal with challenging cases like
the one we saw where you're twisting the
cloth you can twist it right up and it
will still figure out how to inflate
this thing and not introduce any inter
penetration
artifacts um let see the paper for
details it's also
parallelized um by figuring out local
regions to to do this okay so once you
do that then you're able to do
prolongation with these models they
preserve the you know classic shell
energies for symmetric inversions um
they're they're better than the the the
previous cloth approach because they
don't have they have a better better uh
approximation of the energies at finer
scales they don't have parameterization
artifacts as much as Loop subdivision
did and um so they just do a better job
of of course approximations to the model
um and then when you refine them uh
they're better so here's a a shell model
with a with a crush
example and then as you refine the
simulation from here you know you get
something that's consistent uh this is a
Whimsical example where you're
simulating at a coar scale and then
refine it and you get something
consistent uh another inflation
example and um let me just keep moving
along in a run out a time
okay so for
animation this doesn't address animation
so previously we just looked at quasi
Statics and in this new work basically
we can actually add the Dynamics back in
so here's a good example where you have
this character you want to throw them
through some hoops and you're working
with the simulation it's incredibly slow
this is a real-time capture actually
animating this character in Houdini and
it doesn't get through the hoop so you
say oh I need to increase my velocity or
I need to move the hoop or something
like this so it's very tedious to get
these things done but after some work
you know that you eventually get the
character to fly through the hoops this
is using houdin's vum simulator it's a
position-based dynamic simulator but as
you increase the resolution the
simulator changes Behavior so we go to
the next level it does this and you go
oh no I just spent like an hour getting
this guy to go through the dang hoop and
now you know it doesn't go through if
you let it go up another level of
resolution to the full model um this
solver isn't like consistent across
scales this is you know a kind of absurd
example if you had a better simulator
like IPC or finite element shell model
it would have less variation but it
would still be different and so what you
what you can do at one scale you know we
can refine quasi statically but how
about Dynamics how do you refine
Dynamics and still get something that's
consistent across scales and this is
what the progressive Dynamics work does
you simulate something that scale with a
enriched course model with this
multiscale model reduction smarts to it
and then when you refine it you're going
to get something that also produces
qualitatively similar Behavior with now
more detail and so he still Bonks his
nose in in the in the way the animator
wanted and uh as you keep adding more
and more detail you get to the final
simulation so this can run you know
offline but you'll be sure that it's
going to produce something consistent
it's not the same as doing the original
fine scale simulation because it's
biased to be consistent with the course
scale model right so this is the key
thing that gives you
control and uh and so this works for
scenes like this one which are really
complicated on the on the top right you
know here's these Whimsical Sky Dancer
uh uh models where everything gets
designed at the courses scale so that
it's it's it's got the right materials
you know if you've never made one of
these animations before maybe you don't
know the wind speed to use to get these
guys to jiggle and dance in a in a in a
in a fun way um so you have to explore
at the course scale and then you can
refine and you'll get something that
does the same thing not like blows like
crazy or stretches too much or falls on
the floor right so you get consistent
Progressive
Dynamics okay so I don't have time to
talk about the details of this and this
work is just coming out at sigraph this
summer so uh check out ais's web page
for the progressive Dynamics work that
that'll be out uh shortly and that's
that's it for this part of the talk
there's a whole bunch of other results
that show you know basically you get a
scale a flag model that's consistent
across scales whereas if you did a full
simulation just a regular shell
simulation in Orange here after this one
uh basically you get something that
diverges the simulations at different
levels of detail don't do the same thing
which is what you'd hope because
otherwise everybody just do everything
that course scales um okay so that's the
end of that part of the talk the next
part of the talk is this one so I've got
just a little bit of time for
bubbles see um maybe I'll just keep the
questions to the end otherwise I'll I'll
run out oh take take your time dog
okay okay so um the last part I just
wanted to show you some cool work that
um congre along with other collaborators
at at Adobe and and Stanford that we've
done on um making water sounds better so
I'm super excited about about sound
synthesis in general and then water
sounds but here's a here's a experiment
we did back at Cornell where we recorded
lots of droplets and bubble sounds and
the basic problem is that when a
bubble's created it vibrates very
strongly du to compress the air and uh
and the energy of the of the mass of the
water and it could produce notable
sounds in particular so basically have
uh bubbles that have a frequency that's
inversely proportional to their diameter
this has been known for almost 100 years
and um so small bubbles you know produce
these classic you know musical tones in
isolation and this can be used to to
make sounds um but you know people have
have have studied Bubbles and their
properties for how the frequencies
depend on shape how they may couple
together has been explored more recently
and there's this great book by uh Tom
Leighton called the acoustic bubble
which talks about all kinds of things
and people care about this a lot because
for remote sensing for climate models
understand air ocean uh mixing effects
is is is absolutely critical to so many
things we do um in in computer Graphics
um we had a paper back in 2009 that
looked about how does how to use bubbles
to make sound for animations so we
produce various bubbles using stochastic
approach where we would look at how some
particle level set or particles near the
surface would get mixed into the fluid
and then use that to generate bubbles in
a stochastic way and then just use the
minert bubble frequency just based on
the in one over the the diameter of the
bubble and this tended to make the the
sounds pretty shrill like we ended up
with a lot of high-pitch sounds it was
kind of harsh uh you know early sounds
always bad but uh gets better over time
and then so follow on work by Moss said
look they only use this pulsating mode
of the bubble there's these higher mode
higher oscillation modes but these
tended to also introduce higher
frequency sounds which made that even
more you know shrill essentially in my
opinion so this doesn't really solve the
problem and then in order to figure out
how to do better we went to full
two-phase uh flow simulations where we
had incompressible Bubbles and this you
know was computed with with a simulator
called jerus which was very expensive
ran a supercomputer and we got these
more higher Fidelity water simulations
and to see does this make it sound
better and uh so this was a lot more
expensive we also had a solver to figure
out the bubble frequencies based on a
capacitance solver of associated uh LL
problem and we get things like this so
here's what they sound like
so all of these are you have some watery
bubbly character but they're missing
something right um one thing is that the
frequencies are just generally too high
there's the other aspect of the
radiation and the transfer in the air
domain which I'll talk about a little
bit later um these ones on the top
include it this one on the bottom
ignores it but the problem that we had
is a lot of these frequencies are just
higher than we observed in practice and
and one thing that is happening is if
you consider a bubble oscillating
independently it has this damped
sinusoid kind of behavior um but the
frequencies are much higher because when
this bubble is pulsating the coupling
with the neighboring bubbles has been
ignored but in practice if you include
coupling then you get more interesting
variations in this instead of just a
ping of a damped oscillator like we had
before
here which is kind of digital and and
shrill um having this coupling gives
more interesting fluctuations in the
waveform and it also introduces U more
effective mass in the systems the
frequencies are lower and it produces
lower frequency sounds which is really
fundamentally important when you go to
the ocean and hear a giant wave crash
the bubbles are really tiny if you
played them all as independent
oscillators with the one over diameter
frequency it would be just just shrill
and and loud as can be but when you
introduce coupling the ocean gets lower
frequencies and Roars and this has been
known in in U uh acoustic bubble
Community for some time so here's this
example by Leroy where they basically
couple a small number of bubbles
together and you already get reduction
from 3 khz down to like you know 2 point
whatever and in practice if you have
like you know increase the number of
bubbles in some test volume by factor of
a thousand you can get a and or like a
10 times reduction of frequency so
that'll get you from 2 khz to 200 HZ and
gives you a low frequency Roar and so
this is the key thing that we want to
include and which was missing in all
these previous works so in this case we
have an uncoupled simulation on the left
um which is uh which is coming in and
and you get something like this in the
spectrogram and um on the right we have
a recording of a of a different but
comparable scenario and what you have is
this lower frequency lobe that comes in
have the stuff near the surface which is
splattering as increasing as it as it
pours fills up the glass the resonance
increases but you have this lower
frequency effect which is we argue due
to
coupling and uh so this is what was
missing before or one of the things that
is missing and we want to look at
that um and so here's a here's an here's
a preview of our results
I argue that this is fundamentally
better than what we had before um this
is being computed with the coupled
bubble oscillators but also the sound
radiation is doing a Time domain wave
equation and here's the previous
uncoupled results with the better wave
equation so as it pours in the bubbles
just all sound the same
frequency all the time they don't have
the variation in the pitch um and so you
can see this down here you can see these
this cou Ling adds this lower frequency
lobe which we were hoping to get and at
any point in the simulation you can look
at the modes of oscillation of this
bubble cloud and see what's going on so
the low frequency mode is lower than any
of the individual bubbles by quite a
bit um okay um so these simulations were
am I doing for time these Sim I'll try
to make hit the time so these
simulations were were computed using
Houdini which is a animation tool that
was used in industry um so this is like
a flip simulation which is a fluid
implicit particle simulation so it's a
single phase flow the bubbles are
created using a particle based model
which stochastically creates Bubbles and
they they split and merge in some
procedural way is very ad hoc so the the
the sound quality is not coming from the
Fidelity of the simulation this is a
very low Fidelity particle simulation of
bubbles uh in this glass pore example
for example and then the cup Lane is
basically the thing which makes it sound
[Applause]
good okay okay so we introduced a
practical framework for simil couple
bubbled sounds it involves a coupling
model based on the mass Matrix and an
efficient way to compute Airborne sound
on the GPU um just to give you an idea
so the basic uh model of a of a bubble
is just an independent oscillator so in
a pressure volume frame we have forcing
due to pressure and then the volume
fluctuations of this bubble are are
modeled here as this V and then so this
is a simple harmonic oscillator if you
have a bunch of bubbles they're all
decoupled simple harmonic oscillators
and when you introduce coupling the
pressure from one bubble can can drive
the other bubbles essentially so um as
you know it it changes its volume
there's some you know incompressible uh
velocity field that causes pressure
changes elsewhere and so this introduces
coupling and if you symmetrize the
system you end up with a a mass Matrix
formulation something like this so you
basically have off diagonal entries in
your mass Matrix coupling these bubbles
together so this is a weird system
usually where you know have like you
know you know used to a sparse stiffness
Matrix but this is basically just due to
the gas in surface tension so it's
diagonal and you have all the off
diagonal coupling in the mass Matrix
which is a bit awkward because if you
want to time step this uh now you have a
a dense Matrix um so the coupling is
smaller if they're farther away but
bubbles come and go so you add a new
bubble you have to increase the mass
Matrix size if you they pops or
something you have to decrease it so
this is introduces uh changes in this
and then you have this problem that you
have the time Step at really high rates
so this is a an awful space to be in
like even if you wanted to do a you know
forward Oiler time step or some you know
midpoint you'd still have like a dense
Matrix you have to solve to do an
explicit Sol method so this is this is
awful and Tiny time steps so the way to
deal with this we we factorize the mass
Matrix cheski and then it's positive
definite we can interpolate the inverses
and they'll still be positive so this is
good um and so this allows us to
interpolate um these factorizations
along the way uh to make something go
fast um The Matrix can still lose
positive definiteness as bubbles get
closer um it's not guaranteed so we
regularize the the symmetrized mass
Matrix and this we can show this fixes
it and then you can also do low rank
update tricks which is um fun um so
here's Like A reproduction of this
classic example where they have a bubble
net and then you can show the modes that
this system produces uh which correspond
to what was observed in in the previous
approach
experimentally and um these are the
modes of the of the bubbles in the glass
example showing a pretty low frequencies
for for this bubble Cloud the lowest
mode which allows it to capture these
interesting effects um the last part is
just the how to compute the sound in the
in the air domain we don't listen to
igen values or bubble frequencies um we
hear air pressure fluctuations so um we
took the previous approach where we had
like a Time domain wave solver with
basically cut cells and you know ghost
uh ghost ghost uh pressures and then we
um basically put this in a a GPU wave
solver um but the problem with this is
that how do we do this on like cut cells
and things like that on the GPU are
really hard to do so um what we're going
to do is we're going to um basically
simplify the way we evaluate the
pressures we're not using the boundary
data sorry I'm going trying to go too
fast here uh um basically evaluate the
the surface accelerations using a
simplified model and then in order to
compute the the the pressure in the air
domain we use a sample and hold approach
um to basically solve uh the the the
waves in the air domain and this is
because there's so many abrupt changes
and popping artifacts the previous
solvers were just not robust they would
die or they would introduce artifacts
even if they worked so what we did is we
we basically just freeze the geometry at
certain times and then used the the the
boundary condition model to evaluate the
boundary data on these Frozen geometries
and then we use this uh parallel and
time approach that came up we came up
with in our previous paper where we can
uh for each of these Sims they basically
generate some non-zero data and get a
sound clip nonzero data sound clip and
then we sum all these together and then
we get the sound to each of these
instances in time it's just like a frame
based sound rendering approach and so
each of these Frozen geometries can use
just a fixed geometry in a GPU solver so
it's really fast and then we sum these
together and get the sound and so we get
a significant speed up and it's a much
simpler implementation over the CPU
implementation this was also so this is
running on a cluster uh in the cloud so
this is much more expensive than it
looks but um even still it's just much
faster uh even on one one GPU okay
um the coupling simulations are on the
CPU but you know they're just doing
cheski and it's very cheap even with h
this number of
oscillators um so here's some results
just visually so as we add coupling we
get more low frequency lobes in in these
things more low frequency character uh
it pushes things down which makes it
sound a little better and for example in
these pouring examples you get these
lower loes of low frequency content
which makes it better so I encourage you
to go look at the videos online um you
can see these uh and hear them at higher
quality than you can probably see over
uh over this WebEx call um so here's the
core example and from a simulation it
has similar character to a recording
although recordings are always better
and and different um for all kinds of
reasons so anyway so adding cup Lane and
and improving the efficiency and
Fidelity of the of the radiated sound is
is our areas that we can improve um so
in the end this adds more low
frequencies makes things sound better
and makes things faster too and uh in in
future and ongoing work we're still
improving this and making it more
practical we want to be able to do all
these kind of effects and and and make
it easy for people to author them but
also not just do water but everything as
well and so our current approach is like
how to make a a unified GPU solver which
supports everything and doesn't suffer
from all the complexities of of meshing
and interface boundary condition
handling and yeah so that's I think
that's it uh I'll just end here and uh
if anybody has any questions I'll be
happy to answer them so thanks so much
for having me youngu thank you thank you
so much for the wonderful talk doc um
okay so let's have a Q&A sessions does
anyone have a questions uh you can
unmute yourself and then ask
questions um m i I have one questions
okay the first part of the talk you talk
about like going from course to the Fine
scales and you know you know um the
cloth clo animation since that was the
the method was applied um I was
wondering because a lot of U uh
simulations we are interested in is like
actual fracture or the crack
propagations um those technique how can
be extended to those you know actual
tearing and not not only the you know
the
bending right yeah I think
um yeah so extending Progressive
framework uh to to fracture and things
like that is yeah yeah it's kind of the
part of the question is like what does
that even mean right like I I think
um um you know if it's a dynamic process
then ex extending it so that you can
tear things in a coarse way and then
refine them and get more detail right I
mean that would that would be a natural
thing to want to do because the process
is very expensive and it's also often
people have artistic goals or um I think
uh a lot of the way people deal with
artistic goals for fractures they have
fracture patterns that they impose or
they have like enrichment functions
where they try to make it satisfy
certain types of interface um uh
displacements and so on for the fracture
um yeah I don't know I think that's an
interesting thing we're interested in
AIS is actually in the call uh she's
done a lot of work on trying to extend
um uh Progressive quasi Statics and
Dynamics to support volumes and other
effects so doing fracture and you know
all these other more complicated
phenomena is definitely something we'd
love to be able to do but yeah lots of
open questions with you know geometry
for sure got it okay um Chima um you
rais your hand I'm guessing you have a
question
hello um thank you so much for the
presentation so I can also maybe switch
on yeah so uh thank you so much for the
for the presentation it was really
amazing I enjoyed it a lot and I learned
many things
today um I have a question uh about the
consistency measures of the of the
methods because um I also am a PhD
student work with reduction uh methods
for uh for physics based simulation for
computer graphics and what we usually do
is that we when we uh have a reduction
method then we compare to what the full
order model solution will give us and
then we have this error measure let's
say compared to the full order model
what what it does but you explained uh
you showed us that sometimes when you
have the very fine mesh it does not give
you the same behavior that that you uh
that you want and like this is sticking
on the nose of the armadel M that you
showed us at the very beginning so I was
surprised that um a finer mesh would not
maybe give me the
the solution that I am aiming uh at so
if if you can please elaborate on the
consistency measures because that that
would be the the main measure and um one
one more thing that is related to the
same
question uh because you also showed us
that when you change the refinement
level of the mes it changes Behavior
so that was just like the whoop jumping
uh example then how do you control the
course level mesh where do you start
from so that you get the level of
details or the behavior that you are
aiming at in your simulations okay yeah
so there's two things happening here so
on one hand there's like the
traditional uh you know refinement
problem that you know predictive
scientists like yourself have where you
have a simulation model at some H you
know discreation level you refine that
make that smaller and it it converges to
this true solution right that's you know
that's a you know well-founded you know
consistent stability convergence you
know all that stuff we know and love um
the thing with Progressive simulation is
um uh you know as you in that model as
you refine the the mesh you get just
different solutions it gets closer to
the true solution but it's not maybe
what you want right because you want to
design at a course scale and and get
something that you like and then refine
it but as you refine it it may do
something different just that's the way
physics is right and so the the whole
trick of the progressive formulation is
to make the course model more expensive
albeit because it's using some things
from the fine scale but not everything
it's not a full fine scale thing it's
still doing a a low Dimension the Matrix
problem you solve is still small like in
dimensional a reduction but it has some
energies from the fine scale elastic
part which make it think it's doing
something better okay and so that allows
it to behave more like a a fullscale
model so that when you refine it it's
still it's still predictive enough that
it it it behaves in in a similar way but
it it it's not um basically allowed to
be to converge to the full thing uh in
in the for example in the Dynamics case
and so it's biased the course model is
better than just a regular course model
because it's using fine scale energies
but it's biased in the way AIS is doing
the optimization for the time stepping
scheme because it's trying to balance
two things for the Dynamics for example
um the Dynamics is balancing one where
it's just going to take a course
simulation and then and then prolong it
refine it so that it's just going up if
you do that you know the course Sim will
be prolonged and every frame will
correspond and look great but when you
play back that fine scale animation it's
going to pop and Jitter it'll wrinkle
this way and that way do it's going to
be incoherent in time the other scheme
is just to say well I'm just going to
you know prolongate the initial thing
and then run all the simulations at each
level independently in time time step
them but now it'll be coherent in time
but there'll be Divergent across scales
so so what what the the progressive
Dynamics approach does it's an Optimizer
for the time it's basically formulates
the time stepping scheme as an Optimizer
which balances two things one you know
how you're solving say backward Oiler in
time but also it's balancing how it it
relates to the course scale basically
it's you know it's using an initial
guess that's related to the course scale
so it's balancing the errors in temporal
Dynamics momentum and it's balancing
errors in refinement across scales and
if it does that right then you get this
whole uh uh space time you know
framework
which is smooth and coherent and that's
that's but it's not predictive right
it's not like an accurate simulation
like you would refine it it's going to
be biased to the course model so you
pick a course model which is good enough
but still fast and then you um and then
you can refine in this this this
SpaceTime framework yeah yes and and the
bias term is is this a string connection
to the course smesh between the fine and
and course smesh the
the uh penality term that you introduce
at the to the energy I guess with the
norm x minus XP something like yeah that
is basically what makes the no so that
that that term um the the difference in
the the changes in in the the position
in a mass weighted Norm basically just
like you can interpret that as just a
kinetic energy uh energy um model in a
if you look at like a position based
frame formulation of backward Oiler in
position based optimization so that's
that's just kinetic energy the thing
that is in for the progressive Dynamics
to work in a coherent way is in the
paper which you know Aris is going to
put on the web any day now I'm sure so
check looking forward yeah looking
forward great thank you for your
questions thank you all right thank you
thank you so much is there any other
questions
well it's
at 9 after 10 9 after 11 so it's
probably a Goods but and if anybody has
any questions feel free to reach out to
me or or either of my students and I'm
sure they'll be able to answer your
questions yeah yeah thank you thank you
thank so much for having meu it's great
to see thank you thank you thank you bye
bye all right that ends the seminar
today okay bye bye byebye